breaking news
rand paul is a [ __ ] [ __ ] box that's
breaking news yeah well right um
apparently
apparently um rand paul has um let's see
let me read it here let me pull this uh
tweet up here um recount has it the clip
even um senator rand paul uh the quote
is now uh secretary anthony blinken
secretary of state anthony blinken is
testifying in the senate today uh about
the
the aggressor that is russia in um oh my
god
rand paul says the countries that have
been attacked georgia and ukraine were
part of the soviet union since the 1920s
secretary blinken says that does not
give russia the right to attack them so
let's watch the clip here of
of um
the bonehead rand paul
probably getting dunked in the [ __ ]
trash
by secretary blink which is not hard to
dunk um rand paul in the trash just ask
his neighbor let's listen
uh it has not attacked
nato countries hang on uh for probably a
very good we could also argue the
countries they've attacked it here we go
uh it has not attacked nato countries uh
for probably a very good you could also
argue the countries they've attacked
were part of russia
well that
we're part of the soviet union yes and i
firmly disagree with uh with that
proposition it is the
fundamental right of these countries to
decide their own future in their own
destiny and not saying there's not but
i'm saying that the countries that have
been attacked georgia that is exactly
what you're saying you [ __ ] box and this
guy is propagating putin's message
from the seat of a committee hearing
this united states senator in our senate
chamber is propagating putin's [ __ ]
[ __ ] message about how ukraine used
to be part of the ussr it's not anymore
it wasn't the soviet union is gone and
ukraine has been a democracy yeah not a
perfect one but it is a democracy and it
is a sovereign nation
so get the [ __ ] over it pluck your head
out of your ass and realize that rand
paul is fighting against democracy when
he's saying this [ __ ] yeah he is
propagating this is a dumb hill to die
on yeah is one of like to to go in and
defend and be like well
uh
justified they are russia right like i
don't know why i said like yoda there
but
uh
russia
like rand paul's coming in he's like
yeah russia uh they're totally justified
to uh attack ukraine and anyone else uh
yeah because a hundred years ago yeah
because 100 years ago
they really they're like they they were
part of the ussr well regardless of you
know vladimir putin's desire to build
the ussr again or or the soviet union um
it doesn't justify
attacks now it's like going back and be
like well retroactively like they're
actually part of it they owned it like
they get to do whatever they want with
it because it's theirs here's a good
example
here's a good example to give rand paul
and all you [ __ ] trump bumpers out
there and you mogladates
here's the example
california arizona and new mexico it
would be in texas it would be like
mexico saying we're just gonna take that
back that's ours it was ours at one
point that's ours how would you feel and
how would the united states respond to
mexico marching across the border and
committing war crimes to take back texas
arizona new mexico california
the part that was mexico at one time how
would you [ __ ]
build a wall morons like that
again this is really [ __ ] dumb it's a
really bad take and the reason why it's
a bad take is because it's putin's lies
that are making their way into our
public record and again i know it
doesn't seem related but this is why you
have to focus when you're [ __ ]
electing your officials with [ __ ] like
230 because rand paul cannot be trusted
to put his hands anywhere on 230 you
cannot trust that [ __ ] trader if that
[ __ ] trader is willing to propagate
putin's message inside our united states
house or senate chamber
then he is willing to put putin's
fingerprints all over any other
legislation
100
100 and the fact that this is you know
again like you said on the record right
it's the same [ __ ] that you know when uh
matt gates was like i've got the
contents of hunter biden's laptop on
this thumb drive one uh why do you have
the contents of the laptop on a thumb
drive that you're just joking around
with two it has now been verified that
things were put onto a laptop after the
fact and three like
you don't have the actual original you
have something that was a copy of
something else so to say that that is
the actual contents or to say that it's
all bad in this in this thumb drive
you know would totally dismiss the fact
of like someone else doing something so
when i look at this i see this as
another thing where you know the gqp
throws in their
uh their voice to
you know um
do disinformation or spread
uh spread disinformation within the
committee so it goes on the record to be
like well they they
you know he made a point for this it
wasn't a great point but he made a point
for this maybe we should reconsider this
right right well margie makes a good
point here reyna proves uh england
taking back the u.s i mean yeah
and go all the way back right
you know but
give it back to the dinosaurs tony the
fact of the matter is it's what linda
from facebook says rand paul is a
russian asset absolutely 100 percent um
even kailyn points it out here john
mccain said it on the senate floor
pointed at rand paul john mccain when he
was still alive he pointed at rand paul
and said you're putin's puppet in other
words wu-tang for children has the
actual clip that we were talking about
earlier i want to watch this watch what
john mccain says about rand paul
legislative session
is the president
is senator from kentucky i object
objection is heard
this guy does nothing but object mr
president i know this is associated to
this
conversation well i mean i mean he
no just like anything
he also objects to his neighbor kicking
his ass right and he's i'm just saying
you know but you look at you look at
anything when you're like oh what are we
doing like what was the uh what was the
c-span uh the vote that was happening
for uh wasn't it yes well i mean yeah he
was the only one left they were waiting
on him i don't know if he was wiping his
ass after he took a [ __ ] or what but
they were they were waiting for hey i
don't know a good 10 or 15 minutes for
this guy in to come in and give us is no
vote of course he was going to vote no
but
i mean you know everyone is always
waiting
rand paul everyone right well let's
let's listen to what john mccain says
here
about his uh rand paul's objection
leaving the floor without justification
or route or any rationale for
the action that he has just taken
that is really remarkable
that a senator
blocking a treaty
that is supported by the overwhelming
number perhaps 98
at least of his colleagues would come to
the floor and object and walk away
and walk away
the only conclusion you can draw
when he walks away is he has no argument
to be made he has no justification
for his objection
to
having
a small nation
be part of nato that is under assault
from the russians so i repeat again
the senator from kentucky
is now working for vladimir putin i
yield the floor
whoosh john mccain did not mince words
when it came to rand paul there yeah um
thank you uh wu tang
for um bringing that to everyone's
attention and posting that from um let's
see if he's
uh never forget the time john mccain
said rand paul works for putin i believe
this was um i i think it was in two
did do
it was during the
um obama administration i believe 2017
yeah 2017. so it was no it was it was uh
after trump march 15 2017. okay so it's
a recent history not ancient history um
let's see if we can find some more clips
of this [ __ ] bonehead um
i don't want to play too many long clips
here of this this worm you know what
if rand paul is a worm maybe we should
give him ivermectin i'm just saying i
mean go for it i mean it looks like the
things in his hair are worms right maybe
maybe he's got worms in his [ __ ] head